peut-on été on était ensemble dans la
vie de ça faisait trois ans et on était
déjà dans documentaire dans le monde du
cinéma et caetera et il s'est passé
quelque chose dans notre vie qui nous a
vraiment fait virer ben on a eu on a eu
un phénomène de poltergeist nous avons
chez nous dans notre parc à bouaye
c'est ça qui est hyper intéressant quoi
dans votre appartement il y avait quoi y
avait des fantômes on a eu des des
objets qu'on volé devant nous oui les
objets qu'on vous a volé c'était moi non
pas pour faire n'importe quoi vraiment
des objets non mais devrait continuer à
laisser à rire mais on a eu 1 c'était
jour la chandeleur on faisait des crêpes
et tour est fini de manger et on va dans
la cuisine et on a notre pot de
confiture qui a traversé la pièce devant
nous a bien s'étendre des premiers est
injuste et nous c'est de la bonne maman
à jamais et donc quoi il a traversé
lover on l'a vu tous les deux vraiment
là c'était pas c'était après il ya eu
d'autres trucs après et après on a eu
notre téléphone quoi qu'est ce qu'il a
fait le téléphone là il a explosé en
fait avant le 5 5
le téléphone le téléphone est parti dans
le salon et la base dans la cuisine
quand il est projeté à 180 degrés faut
il faut toujours bien vérifier je parle
sous votre contrôle quand on loue quand
on achète que la maison n'est pas
habitée c'est vrai alors c'est d'aller
habiter au déterminé alors il ya comment
on fait pour savoir s'il ya six ans
fantômes dans la maison il ya plusieurs
méthodes déjà il faut toujours rester
une nuit une nuit
vous êtes donc vous allez acheter la
maison vous allez dire aux gars frère je
vais rester quand même une idée revient
à 0 nommer ces voix là c'est pour le
coup c'est pas du tout en question des
tarifs les lycées s'est gêné c'est vrai
il faut déterminer les bruits et quand
vous restez une nuit les esprits peuvent
être dérangé parce qu'ils n'ont pas
l'habitude de vous voir donc ils vont
vous parler vous allez entendre des voir
quoi dégage des trucs des des bruits des
gens que vous connaissais pas facile
mais qui parle aux arbres qui
mais c'est pas c'est pas trop mais bon
j'ai juste une petite techniques simples
de protection je sais pas s'il ya vous
la connaissez qui fait quand même
d'aller mais ça il faut le faire
systématiquement et là je plaisante pas
des boules quiès vous prenez des zones
qui reprenait des oeufs alors une fois
là bien entendu une fois la date au
hockey et consommables et vous ne prenez
un projet vraiment le croyant fantôme on
va dire attendons minutes faire savoir
si l'oeuf n'est pas périmées fin en deux
minutes deux minutes attend deux minutes
fortement j'ai moi parce que je veux
vraiment désolé mais pour qu'il se
cherchait des eaux ferais tu vois je
connais donc vous allez aux quatre
croisement les plus proches de votre
domicile
c'est à dire vous sortez de chez vous ah
oui avec 4 e d'accord vous prenez les
yeux vous marchez vous allez au
croisement les plus proches de votre
domicile les 4
vous marchez vous fermez les yeux telle
offre en arrière va vérifier que le fait
bien écrasé sur la route vous n'aurez
aucun problème d'esprit négatif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces papiers du véhicule
merci non mais quoi et vous allez donc
au dos derrière
bien sûr ces deux là c'est pourri votre
truc c'est vrai ce qu'il dit là c'est
vraiment pourri
[Musique]